did the Pope give his Blessing to
same-sex relationships yesterday as the
media breathlessly
reported
no not quite but I understand why you
might think so in a new document for the
dcast for the doctrine of Faith formerly
known as the holy office formerly known
as the Inquisition the church has
declared that priests can give same-sex
couples a quote spontaneous blessing but
not a blessing that is quote lurgical or
resembles marriage no quote clothes just
gures or words that are proper to a
wedding can be included so as to quote
avoid any form of confusion or Scandal
the blessings cannot be connected in any
way to civil unions and quote rights and
prayers that could create confusion
between what constitutes a marriage
which is the exclusive stable and
indisoluble Union between a man and a
woman naturally open to the generation
of children so no the church did not
approve the blessing of same-sex unions
exactly and yet some liberal priests
including one media Savvy Jesuit in
particular who's inordinately obsessed
with weird sex stuff has celebrated the
document as quote a major step forward
and mocked the notion advocated by
conservatives that nothing had changed
so what does this
mean it means I'm sorry to say just
about whatever you want it to mean it
means that the Vatican has not
officially approved blessings for
same-sex unions as many are reporting
but it also means something else
something that affects not just
Catholics not just professing Christians
broadly but everyone it means this is
why I even bring up the story it means
that weaponized ambiguity will cause
Scandal because Clarity is charity and
confusion is not I'm Michael nolles this
is the Michael nolles
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show new poll shows
Nikki Haley gaining on Donald Trump in
New Hampshire is this race totally
locked up or is there a chance that
Nikki is going to sneak through we'll
get to that in just a moment first
though with all of our social
institutions upended it seems like the
very fabric of reality is tearing apart
we need to restore balance to Nature and
that's why I would recommend checking
out balance of nature right now go to
balanceof nature.com promo code nolles
living a healthy lifestyle is not always
easy you need simple manageable routines
to make sure you're getting proper
nutrition every day which is why I'm a
huge fan of balance of nature balance of
nature fruits and veggies are a great
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day day balance of nature uses an
advanced cold vacuum process that
encapsulates fruits and vegetables into
Whole Food supplements without
sacrificing their natural antioxidants
the capsules are completely void of
additives fillers extracts synthetics
pesticides and added sugar the only
thing in balance of Nature's fruit and
veggie capsules are fruits and veggies
there's never been an easier way to get
your daily dose of fruits and vegetables
go to balance of.com use promocode nles
KW for 35% off your first order as a
preferred customer plus get a free
bottle of fiber and Spice
that is balanceof nature.com promo Cod
NS KW for 35% off your first preferred
order plus a free bottle of fiber and
spice balanceof
nature.com promo code nolles a lot of
people listening aren't Catholic and so
they don't really care what the pope or
the Vatican say about marriage and I
totally get that a lot of people
listening are not Christian a lot of
people listening are not religious in
any conscious way so who cares what the
the Vatican has to say about
marriage everybody really should care
because the Catholic Church whether you
like it or not or you're you believe in
it or not or you're a member of it or
not the Catholic church is the oldest
continuously extent uh institution in
the west the Catholic Church whether you
like it or not or don't like it you know
it it it built our civilization it is
the single institution that built our
civilization it affects many many people
around the world and marriage is the
fundamental
political building block
so the the way that those two things
interact the Catholic church and
marriage is going to have effects
everywhere on Earth and it it makes
perfect sense for people to be concerned
here because of the confusion you know
this is this is something in modern
politics that we see a lot it's kind of
like the Bill Clinton political strategy
and I'm I'm not accus accusing anyone in
the Vatican of intentionally undertaking
the strategy but this is how it's being
perceived by a lot of people the Bill
Clinton strategy if you go into a room
with a 100 people all of whom disagree
and everyone leaves the room thinking
that Bill Clinton agrees with them
Barack Obama had a similar strategy go
into a room everyone disagrees and yet
everyone thinks oh that guy's on my side
that guy agrees with
me people with wildly different views on
marriage the fundamental political unit
are going to read this document they're
going to think oh the church agrees with
me fairly or unfairly but that kind of
ambiguity is is going to be weaponized
it is going to cause Scandal and it's
going to cause Scandal regarding the
fundamental political institution that's
very worrisome now speaking of holy
questions turning to a completely
different matter there is a very
disturbing claim coming out of the war
in Israel and the claim is that the IDF
the Israeli
Army shot an elderly Christian woman
woman and her daughter on the grounds of
a parish the Holy Family Parish on
Saturday there's also a claim that
Rockets fire a rocket at least one fired
from an Israeli tank struck a a nun's
Convent a Convent actually for the the
order that was founded by Mother Teresa
so this is obviously a very disturbing
allegation but it's the fog of War so
who knows if it's true we hear these
sorts of claims sometimes it's
propaganda coming from Hamas we hear
these sorts of claims sometimes they're
credible in this case the claim is
coming from a credible person that would
be the Latin patriarch of Jerusalem this
is the highest ranking official Catholic
official in the Holy Land it's an office
that was established in the 11th century
so what happened well the IDF now is
denying it the IDF is
saying uh that they are refuting the
claim that it had targeted a Catholic
parish in the Gaza
Strip uh they are stressing that the IDF
quot does not Target civilians no matter
their religion uh they say they're that
they spoke with church Representatives
about an incident in the Holy Family
Parish but quote no reports of a hit on
the church nor civilians being injured
or killed were raised during this phone
call that they had with church
officials then the IDF says a review of
the idf's operational findings support
this the IDF takes claims regarding harm
to sensitive sites with the utmost
seriousness especially churches
considering that Christian communities
are minority group in the Middle East
okay I don't like this denial because
notice they're not exactly denying it
notice the language the language here is
very very precise the IDF is saying they
they didn't Target a Catholic parish
well okay they might not have targeted
the parish but they might have
accidentally shot these people I mean
the idef just admitted to accidentally
killing Israeli hostages it that were
being held by
Hamas so it it happened I'm not saying
these these things things are uh not
understandable in any way it's the fog
of war and accidents happen that's why
we have clinical terms that are so
ghastly but terms like uh collateral
damage or you
know bad and accidental things happen in
war the IDF is not denying it seems to
me that that a bad and accidental thing
happened they're just saying we don't
Target it then then they go on we don't
Target civilians no matter their
religion they say no reports of a hit on
the church but they were contacted by
Church Representatives about an incident
in the parish what does that
mean I I don't understand why the church
Representatives would have called the
IDF about an incident in the parish if
that did not pertain to some kind of hit
on the church unless unless the IDF is
drawing a very fine distinction here
between the church and the parish maybe
it were some other building maybe it
were a a Convent maybe it were a
dormatory maybe it were some other but
this distinction seems to me to be a
little a little too precise to really
constituted
denial and then you have to deal with
the idf's first statement when the IDF
first came out here they said an initial
review suggests that IDF troops who were
operating against Hamas terrorists in
the area operated against a threat that
they identified in the area of the
church the IDF is conducting a thorough
review of the incident so initially the
IDF seems to admit that they were
conducting some kind of operation around
here and the operation could even have
been Justified to say well we were going
after Hamas Terror ists and we just got
it wrong we just we thought we were
killing Hamas terrorists we killed two
innocent Christians civilians who were
just taking
shelter but
it whatever this denial is it is not
sufficient not sufficient at all seems
very weak and especially that you've got
the claims not coming from some you know
Hamas media Outlet not coming from some
uh islamist news organization but it's
coming from the Latin patriarch of
Jerusalem has a fair bit of of
credibility let's
say the IDF needs to answer for this not
just in in the name of Justice though
that would be good the IDF isra the
state of Israel should take this this
incident very very seriously and they
should answer for this if for no other
reason than out of
self-interest if you are a supporter of
the state of Israel you should be very
very interested in an answer for this
incident because there is nothing there
is nothing in the world that will more
quickly lose support for the state of
Israel
than this kind of an incident then an
unanswered claim that the IDF is sniping
Christian civilians women blowing up a
Convent there is nothing there is
nothing at a time when international
support for Israel is shaky at best and
even in the United States for the first
time in decades is beginning to weaken
there is nothing that will more quickly
crater Western support for the state of
Israel than this kind of a claim if it
goes
unanswered and and perhaps it is the
case that the IDF just says shoot we
didn't mean to do this this is this
looks really really bad we're just going
to try to vaguely talk around it and
hope that people move on I don't think
people are going to move on this has
risen to the level of the Latin
patriarch of Jerusalem and the Pope the
pope repeated this and look some people
have mixed opinions on the pope but when
it comes to Christian civilians being
killed that's going to interest
everybody in the West
it would be good to get an answer for
the cause of
Justice in times of
War bad accidents happen in every war on
every side
uh but even even for the purpose of
self-interest even for the the most and
especially for the most Ardent Defenders
of the state of Israel there needs to be
an answer for this people are not going
to move on from this kind of thing no no
one on the right well perhaps I'm over
stating it no mainstream person on the
right is is a an Ardent Palestine
Liberation activist okay no no serious
person on the right would ever support
Hamas or the radical islamists or
anything like this okay which is why
support for the state of Israel tends to
be much more concentrated on the right
the left is now marching in defense of
Hamas and you know ivy league
universities are talking about how Hamas
committing a genocide on the Jews is
well contextual you know and we need to
just consider written certain pges are
actually totally fine right so the the
right is
is still strongly supportive of the
state of Israel this is the one issue
that could start to break that and so
there there needs to be an answer now
speaking of the Catholic Church there
are a lot of Catholic news stories in
the news today well there's a great
podcast that you got to check out too
and that would be breakfast there's a
lot of podcasts out there most of these
podcasts are people talking about their
intimate lives complaining about how
America's racist how religion is evil
outside of the daily wire it's very
tough to find podcasts that are creative
and enjoyable and intellectual and
handsome you know and of course luckily
there's a great new Catholic podcast I
just heard about podcast it's called
Break fast it is the perfect mix of
entertaining and spiritual Catholic
content breakfast explains the Catholic
faith through the prism of food drink
landmarks and architecture the Catholic
faith is so interwoven into our culture
that we often don't realize it even if
you're not Catholic I know many I guess
most most listeners to this podcast are
not Catholic many aren't Christian many
don't even consider themselves religious
but the Catholic faith is woven into our
civilization the word breakfast for
example comes from Catholics breaking
the fast after morning Mass did you know
Sushi tempura has its roots in the
Catholic faith or how champagne was
actually created by a Catholic monk
named Dom Peron perhaps you've heard of
him the show's creators saw the need for
a podcast that is engaging and
accessible to everyone of any faith or
none at all breakfast is not just a
random assortment of Catholic Rel
relateded facts covers hard hitting
topics and will make you Ponder the
important questions great place to start
is the episode about the Statue of
Liberty what it teaches us about the
true meaning of freedom it's a
challenging episode you won't hear it
from the mainstream media each episode
is around 20 minutes long you can
download the breakfast podcast on Apple
Spotify or anywhere you listen to
podcasts speaking of foreign policy
Nikki Haley is attacking Donald Trump
she smells blood in the water and so
she's going after Trump not on the
economy not even on
on domestic matters on foreign policy
here she is there are things I agree
with the president on I had a good
working relationship with them there are
things I don't agree I don't agree with
the fact that yes we had a good economy
while he was there but he put us $8
trillion doll in debt that our kids are
never going to forgive us for I don't
agree with how he handles National
Security he focused on trade with China
but he did nothing about the fentanyl
flow he did nothing about the fact that
fentel has killed so many of our
Americans I don't think you should
praise Hezbollah I don't think you
should criticize Netanyahu when Israel's
down on her knees I don't think you
should congratulate the Chinese
Communist party on their 70th
Anniversary I think that when it comes
to National Security we don't praise
thugs we let them know where we stand
and we let them know they'll be held to
pay if they do anything against us
that's who I am okay this is Nikki
Haley fully embracing The Establishment
Lane in the GOP
race and it's probably a smart political
move for her this is Nikki Haley saying
the ways in which Donald Trump changed
the Republican party's position on
foreign
policy I am going to change it
back which is
smart Donald Trump upended some aspects
of domestic policy but not too much he
changed the Republican line on domestic
policy a little bit in that he said hey
Paul Ryan the Young Guns the fiscal
Hawks we're done with those guys we're
not going to reform entitlements we're
not going to cut Medicare Medicaid
Social Security we're going to keep them
exactly as
is that was a little bit of a
shift on domestic policy he said hey
we're going to limit illegal immigration
remember he said that we want more legal
immigration than ever so he didn't even
change the GOP line too much on that but
on foreign policy that was a big shift
he said Bush was totally wrong the wars
in the Middle East were stupid Vladimir
Putin's a very smart guy we're going to
stop cozying up to China we're going to
radically change our trade relationship
with China we're going to I'm going to
go meet with Kim Jong-un even though
he's a short fat guy and I got a bigger
butt and I'm gonna blow him up if he
threatens me again and he totally
upended foreign
policy now the the problem for Nikki
Haley's attack here is Donald Trump is
is the most successful foreign policy
president probably of my lifetime I
guess you would give a little bit of
credit to George HW Bush who managed the
collapse of the Soviet Union and who
managed the first Iraq war in a even if
you didn't support going into that war
in the first place it was a relatively
successful War maybe he's the most
successful foreign policy president
since Ronald Reagan who won the Cold War
but but if you're Nikki Haley and you're
attacking Trump on foreign policy what
what exactly are you going to attack
you're going to attack his language
you're going to attack his tweets but in
terms of
results the
guy convinced Putin not to further
invade any more countries that's first
time since George W bush under George W
bush Putin invades Georgia under Barack
Obama Putin invades Crimea part of
eastern Ukraine under Trump Putin just
stops and then under
Biden Putin goes Whole Hog into
Ukraine he for the he
get puts China on his heels in the trade
War he renegotiates NAFTA he takes out
the top Iranian General he destroys Isis
he basically fixes the problem in Syria
and stabilizes Syria after long calls
for Assad to go and regime change in
Syria that that issue all kind of went
away he even gets Kim jongin to play
nice what are you going to attack him
for nothing other than the tweets but
the tweets will be enough to Rally
establishment
support and the tweets will be enough to
justify the foreign policy vision of
people who have a much more expansionist
interventionist liberal imperialist kind
of foreign policy who who will now be
backing Nikki Haley and it's smart for
her because whatever her personal views
are on foreign policy that's the only
lane left and for a candidate like Ronda
santis who's great who's best governor
in America who a really like a lot for
for a a candidate like Ronda santz who
is in many ways trying to split the
difference between those two foreign
policy positions and lean a little bit
more on the Trump side of the foreign
policy
position he's going to wind up in the
middle of the road and get hit by a
truck because he's not going to pull the
Trump people over he's not going to pull
enough of them over to win but he's also
not going to pull the establishment over
which is why the coconut work and other
more establishment GOP operatives are
now backing Nikki Haley so he's going to
be left some would say he's the best
candidate but some would say he's the
worst candidate because he isn't able to
pull enough support to actually have his
own lane now speaking of military
Readiness very disturbing report out
from the US military the Army the Navy
and the Air Force all missed their
2023 recruitment goals they missed their
recruitment goals by combined 41,000
Personnel it's not good the annual
defense authorization bill passed by con
Congress this year stated that active
duty troops will drop to little under
1.3 million in fiscal year 2024 that's
down by 64,000 troops over the past
three years that gives the US military
its smallest Force since 1940 while we
are on the brink of World War III in two
different places in Eastern Europe well
three places actually Eastern Europe the
holy land and potentially in in
Taiwan what does this mean for the US
military it's even worse than just not
recruiting new people the people who
have already been recruited are now
taking to Tik Tok a Chinese platform to
complain about how much they hate the
Army okay this guy says cons of being in
the Army part one no
privacy the pay
sucks uh bad food disrespectful
leadership No
Sleep these are top five reasons why you
shouldn't join a military reason number
one is pay we do not get paid enough for
what we do I'm not here to say that we
get paid pennies I'm just saying that we
don't get paid enough to perform the
mission that is tasked to us reason
number two family you will not see your
family often you might see them on
holidays and and that that's about it I
can elaborate reason number three
schooling now I know you're like whoa
that was a benefit but it's requirements
you have to meet first to be able to get
to that schooling so if you're thinking
about joining because of schooling just
go to school number four if you're a
parent now if you join single and get
married and then have kids that's one
thing but if you're already having a
child and you're thinking about joining
don't you got to think about it boot
camp is between 6 to 8 weeks after boot
camp you go to school that's between 10
days to a year after that you go to
deployment that's between 8 months to 9
months think about how much time you
miss with your child reason number five
you do not have a 100% say on what you
want to
do how do you spell depression this is a
lady in the Army this m i l i t a r y
whining about that the thing about these
complaints that all of these people are
making is they're all totally
correct I know there are going to be
conservatives out there who are
attacking these guys who say how dare
you where's your patriotism what did you
sign up for this crazy that's not what
the military is like no that is what the
mil I've never served in the military
I'm very grateful to everyone who has
have a lot of family members who've
served in the military and what these
guys are saying it's absolutely
correct and the problem the reason that
this is coming out now that people the
reason people are complaining about this
the people that the reason that the
military is having a hard time
recruiting people is because the top
brass the military leadership have taken
away all of the incentives to actually
sign up for the military so now what new
recruits are looking at is just all the
list of negatives that have always
existed we need the military to protect
us and when you you want to protect
yourself you got to check
out Pac Shield right now go to Pak
shield.com promo code nolles whether you
are a parent a frequent traveler or
simply seeking professional safety you
need to check out Pac Shield Pac Shield
is a ballistic insert that fits into
backpacks messenger bags and briefcases
the inserts meet the National Institute
of justice and 3A standards to stop up
to a 44 magnum hack Shield comes in a
variety of sizes and colors plus it
weighs less than most textbooks and
laptops so it can be easily transferred
from bag to bag nice thing about them is
that no one can tell that you've got it
on your person they're extremely
lightweight they're extremely
inconspicuous it's very impressive I
know that it is easier to keep your head
down and not think about potential
threats that you would encounter in
public life but you got to think about
these things you need to be prepared
pack Shield should never be used for any
reason other than personal defense so
pack some protection and some piece of
mind with Pac Shield check them out for
yourself at Pac shield.com promo code
nolles kwes for 20% off that is p a
shield.com promo code nolles KN n wle
for 20% off today our daily wire
Christmas sale is happening right now
give the gift of 30% off of dailywire
Plus for the dailywire fans on your list
this year that includes access to our
new kids app bent key with over 20
titles and hundreds of episodes
streaming now there are new episodes
every Saturday download the bent key app
and access kids content anytime anywhere
on multiple devices whether you are home
for the holidays or traveling to see
friends and family you can enjoy AdFree
uninterrupted streaming to keep the kids
entertained speaking of the holidays
bent key has some magical Christmas
themed episodes streaming now including
a fan favorite Gus plus us if you've not
heard the Christmas song the greatest
gift from Gus plus us yet take a quick
listen joy we got
each and the reason for the season is
the time we'll spend and with one
another and all the liks this year will
shine
brighter cuz love came down and the
spirit's here and we'll spend Christmas
together this
year I think I'm going to start dancing
at that all the way home that is from
Gus plus us Christmas special streaming
now exclusively on bent key along with
shows like chip Chilla mael mlay and
Yeti tales that I let my kids watch why
do I let my kids watch it because they
won't be subjected to inappropriate
messaging and content that disrespects
my family's beliefs there's never been a
better time to join the fight and help
reshape culture right now give the gift
of a daily W plusus membership for 30%
off at dailywire.com
subscribe serving in the military is
very very difficult the pay is bad you
don't get to sleep people yell at you
all the time you have to do a very
dangerous job you don't get to see your
family there are not a ton of benefits
that go along with it so the the reason
you do it the reason that one enlists in
the military is out of a sense of
patriotism because you love your country
it's out of a sense of honor the notion
that it is an honorable thing to defend
your country and it is dishonorable in a
time of crisis in a time of War to say
dodge the draft why else do you join the
military well there's some fringe
benefits uh in part the respect that you
will receive for the rest of your life
people every time they see you and they
find out you serve they'll say thank you
for your
service in part because of the fringe
benefits like schooling GI Bill sends
you to school that's great great way to
pay for
school in part well I don't know I guess
that's about it and the problem right
now is our top brass at the Pentagon and
our entire Society our whole culture
have knocked all of those reasons down
now mock those reasons hold them in
contempt they say patriotism is a joke
this is an evil country founded by
slavers for no other reason to exploit
poor oppressed minorities it's an evil
evil place we continue to perpetuate
Evil all around the world if you serve
your country not only are you not
honorable but you're actually
dishonorable because this place is
terrible that's the first one the second
one what about that what about the the
notion of Honor that it's it's actually
good to go serve your forget about the
country for a second it's just good for
you to go serve we don't have a culture
of service anymore and that's a problem
largely driven by the left by the right
too because the right has adopted a
greed is good mentality in recent
decades and it said that all that really
matters is going out and getting yours
I'm going to go out there make my money
do what's good for me hook up with the
girls I want to hook up with live my
life forget about other people virtue of
selfishness let's go baby let's read
Rand and then go out there and get ours
that's been a I think that is ebbing on
the right I think that view is certainly
on its way out but that was a that was a
big view on the
right certainly in the
1980s 90s
2000s okay what about the the the
respect you'll get from other people
look you're a veteran you know well
thank you for your service sir what are
you talking about since Vietnam we treat
our veterans terribly some people still
support the troops a lot of people don't
they don't get decent care from the VA
when they get here it's there have been
efforts to reform the VA it hasn't gone
very well since since Vietnam Troops
have been spit on they've been called
Baby rapers child Killers all sorts of
terrible
things
uh where's the where's the honor that
you get just the nice you don't I I
presumably one does not serve strictly
for the social honor that that will
confer but that's nice that's a nice
little perk isn't it well that's gone
too so much for that okay final one what
about the GI bill you get to go to
school well the schools are worthless
now they still matter to some degree as
a credentialing Institution for some
jobs you still need to check that box
but we all know that the schools have
been totally hollowed out from within
the schools Focus much less on good
scholarship than they do on the latest
Dei initiative with the 10,000 person
Army of of Deputy assistant Deputy deans
of diversity inclusion and equity whose
entire job it is to make straight white
guys feel terrible about themselves okay
and to talk about how evil the Army is
and how terrible America is and how we
all need to feel awful for the sins of
our country so what's the point oh and
by the way the Democrats are going to
pay for your school anyway eventually
eventually Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders are going to get their way and
they're going to pay for your school
Bernie is actually a little better on
that issue than than Elizabeth Warren is
Elizabeth Warren she's going to get her
way they're going to they're going to
slowly start paying for more and more
college so the the GI bill is not even
an inducement anymore so why would you
join at that point when all of the good
reasons to sign up for the military are
gone all you're left with is crappy pay
you don't see your family you don't
sleep you get screamed at and you have a
very dangerous
job okay don't be surprised when when
the top
brass is is turning red in the face
screaming before Congress talking about
how important it is for the troops to to
learn about the sources of white rage
and critical race Theory and de ey
ideology how important that is for
military Readiness don't be surprised
when no one wants to join I wouldn't
want to join
either now speaking of
progressivism and speaking of the US
Senate John fedman this is a nice little
turn this is actually a nice little
surprise Christmas surprise John fedman
has just come out and said I am not
Progressive he says I am not a
progressive I just think I'm a Democrat
that is very committed to choice and
other things that's no good he's still
super pro abortion but he says but with
Israel I'm going to be on the right side
of that so the Dems are moving very
anti-israel Federman says I'm going to
be
pro-israel he says immigration is
something near and dear to me and I
think we do have to effectively address
that as well L the Democrats are totally
for open borders shipping immigrants up
everywhere except for their own
neighborhoods and John fman says no we
have to restrict immigration actually
the
Democrats are the party of Menendez this
totally corrupt senator who was taking a
ton of bribes pedling American
influence much like Joe
Biden John fedman one of the few
Democrats openly aggressively calling on
Menendez to resign what's this about the
Babylon B observed that uh as John
fedman recovers from his brain injury
he's becoming more right-wing that's
quite a coincidence interesting how that
works but there's something else going
on here too which is John fedman knows
released his his political advisers
know Democrats cannot win
Pennsylvania without normal people and
the working class immigration is a
working class issue the more migrants
that are allowed to come in the worse it
is for the working class because their
wages go down the job competition goes
up it's
bad Pennsylvania is not Los Angeles
Pennsylvania is not Beverly Hills
Pennsylvania is not the Upper East Side
Pennsylvania is a Rust Belt state
John fedman knows he's going to lose his
seat if he alienates normal people in
the working class normal people in the
working class recognize that we can't
just have a totally open
border normal people in the working
class are not marching in the street
talking about from The River To The Sea
the jihadis will be free and we need to
have more pgr on the state of Israel
because contextually you know you have
to consider the purpose of a
genocide normal people just don't like
that okay Democrats can win in
California by alienating normal people
in the working class they already have
Democrats can win even in New York
though it's a little dice here there by
alienating normal people in the working
class they can't do it in Pennsylvania
they can't really do it in
Michigan they can't do it in Wisconsin
they can't do it in Arizona they can't
do it in Nevada they can't do it in the
swing
states which is why
Federman is is leading here because no
matter what his personal issues are he's
lived in Pennsylvania a long time and he
he knows that state a little bit better
and if you're looking at the polls right
now for Joe Biden and you're a Democrat
you got to be real real worried because
as the left kin extremely to the left
that leaves a wide opening for
republicans and by by the way if the
Democrats push their luck too far and if
Biden's approval Falls so so far now
we're at historic
lows then even with all the little
Democrat Shenanigans changing the voting
rules widespread mailin ballot
harvesting fraud will only take you so
far an election has to be a little bit
close to steal it or you have to just be
in a a totally anomalous time like covid
where you've locked down the global
economy boring those
things would be very very tricky for
Democrats on this current path
especially if they don't listen to John
fedman Biden's numbers are awful so
Republicans are seeing a chance here
this is why Nikki Haley is is full steam
ahead and the the way that Nikki Haley
is is seizing what she perceives to be
her opportunity is not by doubling down
on on the right-wing ideas it's by
moderating on every issue and and
expressing her already moderate stances
on a lot of issues including abortion so
here Nikki Haley in an interview on ABC
news expressed her moderation on
abortion she says well I'm look I'm
pro-life but some of these pro-life laws
in the various States they're a little
they're a little harsh they need a
little tweaking it is the right thing
that unelected Justice is no longer
decide this and it's in the hands of the
people I appreciate that Texas went more
on the pro-life side but as we go
through this listen my heart broke for
her because I had trouble having my
children these the states are now going
to have to look at these because what we
don't want to see is a woman with a rare
condition having to carry a baby until
term so that's when a state corrects
itself and says how do we make sure that
doesn't happen again we tweak things all
the time as govern it was the right
decision by the court well the court had
to follow the law the law said that she
couldn't have the abortion now it's up
to the legislature in Texas to say how
do we make sure there are no more Kates
that go through that
that's what you look at as a governor
you don't just say this is golden as a
governor when something happens that CHS
your stomach that says that's not what
this was intended to be you go back and
say okay what do we do to make sure that
the that we are saving as many babies as
possible but also supporting as many
moms as possible it's not as cut and dry
as everybody wants but States will
self-correct to this that's what they
do okay so what what Nikki is saying
here is there was this case where a
woman was pregnant and the doctors said
your baby might have some problems so we
recommend you abort the baby and if you
don't abort the baby you might have a
harder time getting pregnant next
time again seems a little dubious to me
as far as medical advice goes a lot of
the time a huge huge amount of the time
majority of the time I believe that
doctors say oh your child has terrible
conditions oh your child probably won't
live it doesn't turn out to be true so
often they will convince women to abort
their children and had they just allowed
the children to grow they would have
been totally fine not saying that's true
all the time but it's true a lot of the
time and then this claim well you know
if you don't abort your kid if you don't
kill your kid then you might not be a
there's a chance you might not be able
to have kids in the future and and so
what Nikki is saying here is in this
case the woman should have been allowed
to kill her child and we need to tweak
this pro-life law and I you know I like
Nikki Haley very much personally uh
strongly disagree with her view here and
yet I agree
with the political calculus I think
politically this is really smart of
her for the reasons that I've said since
basically the beginning of this
primary you already have Trump trump is
the pro-life candidate he got Ry weight
overruled if you're a disantis supporter
you might say well DeSantis is even more
pro-life than Donald Trump maybe you
could say well DeSantis signed a six- we
abortion ban in Florida and Trump
criticized the abortion ban now a trump
supporter might say well Trump was only
criticizing it because he reflexively
criticized izes everything his opponents
do and Trump got Ry weight overruled and
so he's got a great record on pro- lifee
too and you know whatever you guys can
duke it
out I'm just
saying Trump already claims the mantle
of the hardcore pro-life candidate by
virtue of his first term so if you want
to find an opening in the GOP race there
there are plenty of Republicans who are
not extremely pro-life there are a lot
of
them the the non prolife nonh hardcore
pro-life Republicans are not going to be
supporting Ronda Santos and they're not
going to be supporting Donald Trump
they're going to want a different
candidate Nikki Haley is positioning
herself to be that candidate which is
why she's gaining in the polls now when
we're talking about hiring people not
just to run our country but also to work
at your business you got to check out
zip recruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com if you're a business
owner and you need to grow your team you
want a smart hiring solution look no
further than zip recruiter right now get
the gift of zip recruiter for free at
zip recruiter.com nles kwes now you
might be asking how zip recruiter is a
gift to those who are hiring zip
recruiter uses smart matching technology
to identify the most qualified people
for a wide range of roles zip recruiter
lets top candidates know when they are a
great match for your job to encourage
them to apply the bow on top if you see
a candidate who is a great match for
your job zip recruiter makes it easy to
send them a personal invite so they're
more likely to apply get your hiring
wrapped up quickly with zip recruiter
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day go to this
exclusive web address right now to try
zi recuiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
KW that is ziprecruiter.com
K
wle zi recruiter is very clearly the
smartest way to hire my favorite comment
yesterday is from Karina B who says he
was just analyzing the legislative
matters before the Senate okay all right
that
I think we're referring to
certain video that was filmed in the
Senate Judiciary rearing room hearing
room and we're talking about what some
people have called the insur rectum
and the I don't want to at Le look I
like the jokes okay but I don't I don't
need any more
screenshots I don't there's no reason to
post the screen if you're a conservative
I don't need to see the
screenshots keep it to the puns those
are bad
enough CBS polls showing Haley gaining
on Trump not not nationally exactly but
at least in New Hampshire so in
Iowa Trump is Far and Away the leader
DeSantis comes next in New Hampshire
Trump is faren away the leader Haley
comes next Des santis I think is third
but Haley is gaining pretty
significantly H and it's not even just
in the head-to-head polls it's on all
sorts of issues so
2024 who would you likely vote for today
in New Hampshire 44% Trump 29% Haley 11%
DeSantis 10% Christie 5% V ASA
Hutchinson still in the race do you
remember that so uh it's not really
close with anyone other than Trump and
Haley 44 to 29 it's still a huge margin
but it's with within sight at
least Iowa DeSantis still far ahead of
Haley but still far behind
Trump now when you get into the cross
tabs here New Hampshire who would you
describe as prepared 54% say Trump 53%
say Haley 44% say to santis Trump and
Haley virtually tied describe described
as likable who's the most likable
candidate in the race or who are you
more likely to describe as likable 55%
say Haley the majority clear majority
37% DeSantis 36 ramaswami 36 Trump so
DeSantis ramaswami Trump all to
chrisy very unlikable Haley Far and Away
the most likable according to New
Hampshire voters described as reasonable
51% say
Haley 37% DeSantis 36% Trump and
disantis tied Haley Far and Away the
winner and most likely to be described
as reasonable described as a strong
leader 66% say Trump 45% DeSantis 41%
Haley everyone else way down so dtis
still has an edge on Haley but close to
being tied Trump far away the winner
there most likely to beat
Biden 51% say
Trump 32% say Haley 27% D santis so
Haley and D santis within Striking
Distance but Haley still has the edge
Trump has a huge
lead on and on more cross
tabs that's good news for Haley that's
big news for the Haley campaign you know
how much I hate to say I told you so
but I did call it I did call it from the
beginning of this race
that there were two lanes there's the
Trump Lane and there's the not Trump
Lane that's it and probably it doesn't
even matter who's in the not Trump Lane
because of the unique circumstances of
the almost unique circumstances of this
race we haven't seen a race like this in
over 100 years a candidate who was
president who is now running for a
non-consecutive second term it's weird
but Trump is going in effectively as the
incumbent so the non-trump candidates
really got to be non-trump which means
it's going to be tougher for disantis
it's going to be easier for a candidate
like Nikki Haley and she's capitalizing
on that meanwhile other Republicans are
consolidating around Trump uh Josh Holly
senator from Missouri Republican just
endorsed Trump said Trump president
Trump doesn't need to worry I'm with him
he's asked me several times to support
him I said yes and I've been saying for
a year that I think he's going to be the
nominee I support him I'm going to vote
for him don't worry you can put me down
as support Endor stand withth so this is
a little bit of a tepid endorsement here
he's not saying Trump is my man he can
do no wrong I totally saying yeah I'm
with him he's asked me for a long time I
previously did not say yes I am saying
yes now because I think he's going to be
the nominee he's saying all of this this
is a consolidation now of people who
whether they really like Trump or
they're they're lukewarm on Trump or
they don't even like him these are
people who think they see the writing on
the wall now this this endorsement came
two days after Trump threatened Josh
Holly and Ted Cruz Trump posted on his
social media Network he said so
interesting that the Dems are looking
hard at the Senate races in both
Missouri and Texas Josh and Ted must be
very careful stranger things have
happened three exclamation
points so we'll see I don't think
Senator Cruz has endorsed Trump yet uh
hly has you're going to see more and
more come along as a consolidation
happens now speaking of writing on the
wall and writing in all sorts of places
a Seattle high
schooler was just marked in correct on a
quiz for saying that only women can get
pregnant uh there was a
quiz on on understanding gender versus
sex this was administered by a 10th
grade ethnic studies world history
teacher what what are they teaching in
school at ethnic studies world history
at Chief SE International High School
and the student was marked wrong for
answering the question that uh all men
have
penises as a true statement and also
marked wrong for saying that only women
can get
pregnant is a true statement so for the
first question I guess there are freak
accidents right I guess there are kind
of know surgeries going wrong or you
know I get technically speaking I guess
not all men
do no women do but some I guess some you
know God forbid like awful you know but
could be a freak accident but then the
second one only women can get pregnant
that leaves No Doubt
obviously only women can get
pregnant but then Zoom back out what
class is this in ethnic studies why are
you sending your kid to study ethnic
studies that's a that's a pseudo
academic discipline that is strictly
from the very beginning it is only ever
been a a political operation to
indoctrinate students in a far- leftist
ideology deriving from critical theory
and the the various critical studies
departments that proliferated in the
universities now apparently in high
schools in in the 60s and 70s
then furthermore what's the quiz the
quiz is called understanding gender
versus sex so if you believe that there
is a hard and fast distinction between
gender and sex and the two have nothing
to do with one another as the left
believes if that's the premise of the
quiz then I got to ask
you why are you sending your kid to this
school you know what you're getting
going in the school is not being
dishonest
here look I think there's a distinction
between gender and sex I know it's not
popular for a lot of conservatives to
say that but I think there is and I
think it's it's really a modern liway of
talking about the distinction between
the body and the soul I disagree with
the way the libs talk about the
distinction between gender and sex
because I think that the body and soul
are inextricably linked and the soul is
the substantial form of the body so I
think that you know if if you f if you
feel a disagreement between your gender
identity and your sex the reality stems
from your biological sex because I think
that sex and gender derive primarily
from the matter of the body not from the
form of the soul and it applies to the
person as a as an Inseparable accident
of the individual for as long as you
exist as an
individual okay I bet that that's
nowhere on that quiz but that's the way
that our civilization has thought about
gender and sex for all of
history so if you want to teach your
kids that you you can't send them to
this
school if you are a parent why would you
SE subject your child to this and
furthermore forget about the parents I
don't know the circumstances maybe it's
the only School in the neighborhood what
kind of country subjects students to
this what kind of country intentionally
Mal educatees
students intentionally alienates them
from reality makes them Dumber makes
them confused about who they are and
potentially entices them to fall into
ideologies that will harm them and and
may well reduce their life expectancy
but but furthermore just what kind of
country puts their kids in classrooms to
make them stupider and more ignorant our
country does that
that's very sad it's very unfortunate
there's no no surprise here that that
parents are pulling their kids out of
school now and homeschooling it's very
difficult to do that in our modern
economy where both parents are working
and a lot of people just maybe they can
make it work but it's going to take a
little while even to Pivot what kind of
country does
that not not a great one not a not a
country that is as great as it once was
it's a country that needs to be made
great again the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member use code noes can a
checkout for 2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans